Manas videos long-overdue passion
project my friends that's what this
video is passion project I don't know
it's not a review I just kind of want to
give you my thoughts on this game with a
cult following which I am definitely a
part of that I love so much how many
different versions of this game - IO and
hold on let's count them out digital ps4
hardcopy PS Vita digital PS Vita can't
get the Platinum on either and that bums
me out that's really lame I hope they
patch that Digital Nintendo switch hard
copy collector's edition on Nintendo
switch and the Sega CD oh and the mega
CD version from Japan let's try to have
the Sega CD and mega CD version it's
different in debt is love my friends so
yeah I've referenced this video game in
videos before I just kind of want to
give you my thoughts as to why I love
night traps so much and this isn't a
history lesson on night trap in a 25th
anniversary edition that limited-run
Games released there's actually a really
fascinating behind-the-scenes making-of
which is also on the youtube channel my
life in gaming so I'll put a link below
go check that out if you want I guess
they were the ones behind that
documentary they're one of my favorite
channels on YouTube and most importantly
they're good people just want to make
sure good people are taken care of so go
show them some love so as this is not a
history lesson for night trap it's just
me talking about night trap because my
traps [ __ ] awesome night trap came
out for Sega CD I believe it was 1992
we'll just call it the early 90s and
holy [ __ ] Congress did they lost their
minds over this which is hilarious you
just watched the videos of Congress
talking about this game I find that so
extremely offensive and the only word
you can say to the manufacturers and the
shareholders of the company is shame on
you the narrative that was spun is that
you stock and kill women or you hang
women on meat hooks or you rape them
none of that [ __ ] happens in I trap
there's a phrase and this phrase comes
to my mind when seeing that video which
is feelings are real but they're not
always reality not only can you go to
any corner of social media and see that
in action but that's what I see in
action when I see those videos these
Congress people really felt that they
were dealing with the most heinous piece
of video game entertainment that would
ever be made but in reality what they
were dealing with was a cheesy fun can't
be video game but any metric
their feelings were real to them but
they were not reality suppose if they
did a little due diligence they would
have learned that but I doubt any of
them really did so the premise of night
trap is there's this house they're a
family of vampires and there are these
augers who really look like putty
patrollers from Power Rangers meets
ninjas the story is they're vampires
zombies their skin sloughing off so
that's why they're dressed like putty
patrollers this group of girls goes to
the house for a slumber party and the
augers are invading the house you've
hacked the surveillance system as well
as the traps
so you use the cameras to peek in on the
eight rooms in the house and when an
augur steps over one of the traps push
the button at the right time and you
trap the augurs today you're there to
take out the bad guys and save people
shame on you
you can't watch too much of the story
and missed too many augers otherwise BJ
honey cuts gonna cut you off my brother
and I called him BJ Honeycutt cause he
looks like Honeycutt from mash I'm just
saying I think some of the initial
enjoyment I had with this game comes
from the phrase a fly on the wall like
I'd love to be a fly on the wall da da
da da right there's a fascination in
looking in on a conversation or a room
full of people they don't really know
you're zyre enticing thing about the
Invisible Man Holloman call it what you
will
you get and in this you it kind of was
that I was like well I'm really looking
in on this house it's but it feels real
it feels real because it's well fleshed
out especially when it came out there's
another thing I like about the making-of
is you see the timeline the timeline has
to line up it's like filming this thing
was like okay this person's gonna enter
that room and so you have a minute and a
half to do your lines deliver the lines
and that person needs to exit because
we're gonna film another scene where
they come into that room must have been
a nightmare to film but they did it well
enough to where this house feels like a
living breathing thing there are
conversations and interactions happening
and that one leads to that one and these
people are talking over there in the
kitchen maybe you want to peek in on
them the next time you play you want to
peek in on the living room
[Music]
[Applause]
if that song doesn't get stuck in your
head I mean granted not everything that
lines up there are a couple of augers
that come into the kitchen it's like you
should have come from Hall one but you
didn't just appear there another scene
where Danny the little kid screaming his
ass off because hours are coming after
him and everyone's talking in the other
rooms like none of you hear that kids
screaming bloody murder no okay
those facts so there was a weird replay
value for me with night trap because
it's like when I play I'm looking for
augers but maybe I want a peek in on
this room the next time maybe I want a
peek in on that room maybe I want to
follow this person their goings-on maybe
I want to follow this other person the
point is the game is not nearly as
heinous it was made out to be because
when I first got an eye trap I was like
whoo I've heard about this I feel like
I'm gonna play a game I'm not supposed
to play I feel like I'm breaking the
rules it was exciting I played it I was
like I mean when it comes to video games
maybe it's the most or not no it doesn't
really look and all its it's just not
that violent as seen as the rerelease
got a teen rating the game that started
the ESRB rating for games has a teen
ratings ironic well actually it's not
just night rap when people talk about
the rating system and where it started
for games people either talk about night
trap or Mortal Kombat in my recollection
it was both like both just in tandem
created this perfect storm for Congress
people to just melt the [ __ ] down and I
do profess at a rating system for video
games I think that is a good thing is
the thing that needed to happen it
probably needed to happen around when it
happened but looking back night trap
being the thing that sparks that
conversation well that's that's strange
the game is obviously going for camp any
one of two possibilities is that they
tried to make something scary is just
cheesy sand I was like no no we totally
meant for it to be cheesy yeah the whole
time it's totally intended or they
actually meant for it to be cheesy I'm
just saying there's one scene where
augers give high five obviously it's not
taking himself that seriously the
infamous scene is the scene where the
auger is waiting in the shower for the
girl and that was a scene that was shown
in Congress and this is why this games
video games horrendous but for me that's
things interesting because that actually
elevates the auger consciousness I mean
granted they do use these sticks with
collars at the end that go around the
neck and drain blood in very pg-13
fashion but nowhere else in this game
does a show an auger lion wait that's
the only time an auger lies in wait so
I'm like okay they're not just zombies
with some tech now they they have
sentient consciousness and they can
tactically plan that's what that
sickness to me the best actor in night
trap granted the bars not that high this
game is over acted to shed we're not
going for Oscars here but I mean come on
victors the best right not just because
of my favorite line he has a woman's
intuition again but over the youth if
we're just picking the youth Jeff is
probably the best actor maybe it's
because he just naturally has his lines
flowing because he probably knew what
this was it was probably like oh this
isn't my big shattering that was alright
let's get through right I gotcha
gotcha yeah you just seem the most
natural to me every console generation
or new technology has that first wave
that's just it's a showcase for the tech
I was Sega CD it's like we can have
video and video games we can put the
video elements in video games Wow super
shark night track corpse killer let's
bring it on that's what night trap kinda
was but in terms of those games this was
the most interesting to me it was
weirdly immersive especially first time
in the Sega CD version that I played
when the dudes givin you the lecture at
the beginning he holds up the controller
he's like this is your controller this
is how you control the traps I'm like
holy here's the same controller so you
feel like the character you play is you
sitting on your couch watching this
house from your TV and you're actually
trapping these augers it was probably
the most immersive game I had ever
played at the time night trap weirdly
lives on there's something endearing and
charming about the cheesy cam penis of
this game it's with horror elements that
are like alright is it horror is it a
spoof of horror
all I know is I don't feel too weird the
fact that this did get a 25th
anniversary re-release and it sold out
like a [ __ ] so I'm not the only
one who loves this game I thought I was
for many years because I'm nice but the
rerelease has much higher resolution
video I got on the Sega CD is that
videos Wow yeah it's rough not only does
the re-released have higher resolution
you see more of the frame of the video
but also for the icons you don't just
have a cons you see the video down there
in the icon so you can see when an auger
pops into a rooms you can just go down
there and catch him which I'm not gonna
lie if that's a point of pride it's all
the more impressive back in the day I'm
not [ __ ] with you on this can't
believe I'm gonna admit this but I'm
going to with pride back when I first
played this game for the Sega CD in the
early 90s I mapped out on a piece of
paper all the time codes and all the
locations of all the augurs in this
entire game there was no game FAQ there
were no trophies I did it for me
they took a lot of playthroughs which is
why going through all the playthroughs
to get the Platinum in this game that
was nothing to me
I was like but I only have to play
through a few times I played through the
game a lot more than that I also could
have gone for the sounds like in the
Sega CD version when you miss an auger
it makes this sound it goes so you know
oh I missed an auger where was that
auger now it doesn't make a sound so you
don't get an audible notification that
you've missed an auger is gone for that
in the remade fact is I just love this
game and sometimes I've seen it go on
sale for about five or six bucks
definitely worth getting for five or six
bucks just to play some weird piece of
video game history none of their games I
love that I recognize aren't technically
perfect but night trap in its own way is
impressive for what it was back then the
vision that they had to make this
weirdly immersive interactive piece of
horror parody filming it all to line up
and having the scenes that take place in
multiple rooms all line up with the
timeline is just respect especially now
seeing the interviews and hearing about
the production it's clear that they were
just out to make something fun that
entertained gamers and they went to
great lengths to make this video game as
nonviolent as humanly possible
I love this cheesy bit of videogame
history my one hope is that Sony patches
the Vita version which at
it was unbeatable the Vita version would
just freeze up when Kelly goes into the
last holiday for the last name it just
frees up was like nope no more game for
you so they patched that but there's
still three other trophies that don't
unlock and they're unattainable so you
can't get the Platinum I hope it gets a
patch one day I know Sony doesn't
support the Vita anymore but there are a
lot of Vita owners who supports Sony
still so I just hope it happens because
what's better than one platinum four
night trap to Platinum's four night trap
that's right it's good it's bad it's
cheese it's fun it's historically
interesting but I think it might just be
the greatest bad video game of all time
iczer night trap have you played it did
you love it back in the day did you hate
it back in the day have you played it
recently for the first time do you love
it do you hate it what do you think a
night trip whatever you think comment
below let me know and as always if you
like what you've seen here and you want
to see more click right here to see more
you